همم عاجل مثلما همم تابعتهم همم في هذه
النشره على الهواء من خلال العواجل التي
تظهر اتباعا على همم شاشه الجزيره هذه
الصور وردتنا قبل قليل من العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس همم ما بعد عمليه لا نعرف
ما هي تحديدا ولكن ذكر مراسل والجزيره بان
سته جرحى همم
في حادث الاطلاق نار في الدائره العاشره
تحديدا في باريس معي محمد البقالي مراسل
الجزيره من هناك محمد ما الذي حدث
اه لحد الان في الحقيقه مازال هناك اسئله
كثيره تحيطه بهذا الحديث لم تعرف تفاصيله
او على الاقل الدوافعه لكن الحديث معروف
شخص في ستين من العمر اطلق النار على
مجموعه من الاشخاص داخل احد المراتب لا
تعرف الاسباب ولا تعرف الجوافه الحقينا
المؤقته لحتى اللحظه هي جرحها على الاقل
خطيره للغايه كان هناك حديث عن وفاته لكن
صديق على انها فتاه لم تتاكد ولكن يمكن ان
نقول ان القصيره الموافق
على الاقل
هذه الدائره العاصمه هي همم المكان الذي
تم اطلاق على هذه النار
للغايه فيه عدد كبير من المراكزاليه من
المحلات يشهد حركيه كبيره خاصه خلال
هذا اليوم الذي يصدق اعياد الميلاد لحدث
تاكد تاكد مقتل شخص الان تم الاعلان عن
تاكد او يسمى اخبار نادي انه بالفعل همم
الشخص الذي اعلن عن وفاهه اا تاكد هذا
الامر اذا وفاه صخر
لم يعرف لم يحدد عددهم اكثر هذه هي
الخطيره الاولى لان الحقيله ما زالت
مفتوحه التوافق هذه الشرطه تمكن من اعتقال
الفاعل محمد همم هل هل هو همم بعد اطلاق
النار عليها هل هو
بالصحه يمكنه من خلالها تقديم ربما
الاسباب التي ادت همم الى هذه الفعله
بحتى اللحظه تم الحديث على ان الشخص في 60
من عمره وان ملامحه حقوقازيه مهند لا يعطي
الشيء الكثير عن الدوافع بالترتيب ما دام
الفاعل حيا وتم قاله على قيد الحياه فهذا
سيمكن الشرطه من التعرف على خلفيات هذا
الهاتف على دوافعه وهو الذي ربما السؤال
الذي يطرحه الان الجميع في فرنسا لان مثل
هذه الهجمات فرنسا قد شهد هجمات كبيره
وكان اثارها على المستوى النفسي على
المستوى السياسه على المستوى الاجتماعي
كبيره جدا عرفت فرنسا خلال الفتره الماضيه
نوع منها الهدوء تراجع كبير هذه النوع من
العمليات والعزمات الان هذه العوده في
الحقيقه في هذا التوقيت الان تثير الكثير
من المخاوف الكثير منها القلق والسؤال
الاساسي الان هو التواضع هل يتعلق الامر
في توافي نفسيه شخص مختلف عقليا ربما ان
في ثبات احيانا
احنا يعني او
لديه دوافع ارهابيه هذا الامر لا يمكن
الان ان نستعجل في الحفل فيه لكن الشرطه
الان تحقق الموضوع وقد دعت الفرنسيين
والناس الى عاد تجنب هذا المكان والابتعاد